[Musique]
ce
l'anonymat sur internet n'existe pas
c'est un pseudonyme a c'est à dire que
en principe les personnes qui sont
connectés elles ont une adresse ip
d'arrêt les adresses ip raccrocher à un
fournisseur d'accès est normalement on
peut trouver le lieu de connexion sont
d'origine l'anonymat sur internet c'est
comme aller se promener dans la rue on
n'est pas obligé de décliner son
identité chaque fois qu'on sort de chez
soi et qu'on va dans l'espace public
internet est un espace public donc
supprimer la ligne l'anonymat tel quel
au départ comme ça a priori non il n'en
est pas question
[Musique]
dès lors que l'on met en place un
système juridique telle qu'il
envisageait par la proposition de loi la
crainte elle est ici de devoir des
risques de sur censure qui se produisent
vis-à-vis des contenus dont l'illicéité
n'est pas totalement manifeste
j'aimerais pas être à la cresse d'un
hébergeur parce que son avenir est
compliquée avec un telle ou telle
logique tisser l'état sous la forme
administrative
je pense que c'est pas de le faire je
pense que c'est aux juges de faire le
ménage
c'est en tout cas de façon sûre pas
l'hébergeur pas au site pas aux réseaux
sociaux
[Musique]
je dirais que c'est cette lutte contre
les contenus qui sont manifestement et
ne l ait une garantie des libertés
d'expression
c'est justement parce que il faut lutter
contre les abus les plus violents les
plus manifestes que cette contrainte
permet d'assurer la liberté d'expression
des échanges des échanges on va dire
raisonnée et raisonnable entre entre des
personnes ne peut pas être aussi
péremptoire je pense que là la
modération des contenus sur les réseaux
sociaux va entraîner une sur censure et
donc peut porter atteinte de façon assez
significative à la liberté d'expression
que ce soit la fin de la liberté
d'expression j'ose espérer que non ce
serait trop radicale mais je pense que
ça va en tout cas uniformiser les
contenus et les rendre beaucoup avec
beaucoup moins de relief et d'aspérités
et donc porter atteinte à la liberté
d'expression
il
[Musique]